I have a video for you today that might make
you cringe.
It's actually pretty hard to watch because
it's a video of embarrassing erroneous and
egregiously ego maniacal
Republican Senator Ted Cruz, who went on NBC
news over the weekend and the studio audience
laughed in his face when he tried pushing
a totally debunked conspiracy theory.
This is probably one you've heard me mentioned,
Republicans have been pushing the conspiracy
theory that Ukraine actually metaled in the
2016 election.
And the point of this is to indirectly sort
of try to justify Donald Trump trying to extort
Ukraine to smear Joe Biden in exchange for
releasing military aid and having a meeting
between president Zelenskyi and Donald Trump
at the white house.
This is now subject the subject of the impeachment
articles that Democrats announced today.
So it's a conspiracy for which there is no
evidence, but the true Trump Brown nosers
continue to push it.
Check out what Ted Cruz had to say.
Notice that the crowd starts laughing at him
and um, this, this is how it went.
Do you believe Ukraine metal in the American
election in 2016?
I do.
And I think there's considerable evidence.
You do.
And Chuck, let me say this is Senator, this
sort of strikes me as odd because you went
through a primary campaign with this president.
He launched a birtherism campaign against
you.
You went after your faith.
He threatened to quote, spill the beans about
your wife, about something.
He pushed a national Enquirer story, which
we now know he had a real relationship with
the editor.
You're driving up all that garbage.
Is it?
Let me ask you this.
Is it not possible that this president is
capable of creating a false narrative about
somebody in order to help him politically?
Except that's not what happened.
The president released the transcript of the
phone call.
You can read what was said on the phone call.
Now, of course, this is one of the big lies
that they tell over and over and over again,
and it sort of starts to become the truth.
They did not release the transcript.
Ted Cruz refers to the transcript.
They're talking about the July 25 phone call
between Donald Trump and president Zelenskyi.
That was a more than 30 minute phone call.
They released a few pages of the transcript.
It is not a transcript.
It's an excerpt, but they continue to call
it the transcript, but that's not really what
we're looking at today.
What we're looking at today is how Ted Cruz
is still willing to repeat the Ukraine meddling
conspiracy absent any evidence, and fortunately
the crowd laughed at him.
I actually like that Chuck Todd, who I'm not
a particularly big fan of at all.
Chuck Todd actually brings up to Ted Cruz.
Why are you doing this, Ted?
Why are you doing the president's dirty work,
particularly after he attacked your wife's
physical appearance?
He implicated you in bizarre conspiracies.
He went after you endlessly.
He nicknamed you lie in Ted and it stuck.
He seems to have pushed a tabloid that he's
connected to to print a completely bogus story
about you.
Why is Ted Cruz doing this?
Maybe there is something to be said for studio
audiences trying to apply shame to Republicans
who say ridiculous things.
Maybe shame is the only workable strategy
we have left.
We know that as far as Donald Trump is concerned,
he seems to be unable to feel shame, but maybe
some of these other Trump Brown nosers are
able to feel shame and maybe it gets them
to rethink the things that they're publicly
saying.
I'm thinking out loud here.
It may do nothing at all.
Now, as a side down, as I mentioned, Donald
Trump went after the appearance, the attractiveness
of Ted Cruz's wife.
If you are Ted Cruz's wife, and you know that
that happened during the Republican primary,
and it's not just an attack on Ted Cruz, it's
it's Trump going after Ted Cruz, his wife's
physical appearance, and then Ted Cruz is
out there pedaling the same type of stuff
to placate Donald Trump day after day after
day.
It's going to be a little weird for Ted Cruz,
his relationship behind the scenes.
Now, does anybody uh, agree with that?
Let me know what you think.
But the bigger picture here is that, you know,
we talked at the top of the show now that
Democrats have filed articles of impeachment,
what are going to be the Republican strategies
in order to try to defend Donald Trump's actions?
Number one, of course, of course it's going
to be that the entire desire to impeach Donald
Trump is not based.
In fact it was decided back in 2017 blah blah
blah blah.
It's a witch hunt.
It's a hoax.
That's all it is.
That's going to be one argument.
Then they will get to uh, arguing that none
of the witnesses whose testimony led to articles
of impeachment were fact witnesses.
They will talk about, it was all hearsay.
That's another layer which they are going
to use to try to sow disinformation around
impeachment.
And then number three likely is going to be,
again, Ukraine was super corrupt.
Trump was right and what he did Ukraine metal
than the 2016 election.
Trump was concerned about it despite the fact
that we've heard testimony from numerous witnesses
now that Donald Trump never expressed concern
about corruption in Ukraine, uh, prior to
this, uh, request for a favor that took place.
So Ted Cruz deserves to be laughed at for
this.
Glad that the audience did, but this Ukraine
in 2016 thing is not going to go away.
And I wouldn't be surprised to see it play
a larger and larger role in the context of
the upcoming, uh, what, what may be an impeachment
trial in the Senate that we seem to be heading
in the direction of.